hi I'm Eric Voss and this is the
breakdown of Rick and Morty season 3
episode 4 indicators 3 the return of
world Enders this episode was my
favorite so far in season 3 maybe just
because it's one thing that I love this
is telling mocking another thing I love
with Rick trapping a pseudo Avengers in
a violent saw scenario but yeah this
also had that classic rick and morty
blend of great jokes subtle animation
details and heartfelt themes so let's
dive deep and discuss everything that
made this episode great
who knows maybe we'll catch a few things
he didn't notice ok so right off the bat
this opening scene introduces us to the
existence of these indicators a team of
intergalactic superheroes that Morty
idolizes so this whole episode is Rick's
critique of the Marvel and DC movies and
let's review all the ways this episode
parodies the superhero genre some more
subtle than others so the indicators are
obviously modeled on teams like the
Avengers regarding to the galaxy maybe a
little Justice League x-men and
Fantastic Four thrown in there too
notice how Morty calls them to the
guardians with the unguarded and these
slugs whose DNA could cause human
sterilization seems like a nod to the
sci-fi sterilization trope from children
of men or The Handmaid's Tale but
remember this was also a plot point from
the movie Logan mutants stopped
reproducing and were dying off because
of a toxin in the food supply and next
Rick says this about the v' indicators
there are a bunch of drama queens it's
been an hour talking and 20 minutes
jumping around while [ __ ] blows up their
a phase we did one it was the big event
of that summer let it die so the
terminal phase may apply to the phases
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe which
Rick obviously thinks should have ended
with the drama queen in fighting and
explosion jumping of the first Avengers
movie now this scene also hints at those
phases when Morty Cheers we're doing
Vindicator so of course this episode is
min Decatur's three more day learned
later that he missed their second
adventure when they fought doom nama
tron a reference to Ultron the villain
of the second Avengers movie so
Vindicator 3 is a parody of the third
Avengers movie infinity wars with Santos
Santos is certainly a character who ends
world he's clearly an inspiration for
world ender along with characters like
Darkseid from DC and Galactus devourer
of worlds from the Fantastic Four but
the twist in this episode is
world ender isn't the real threat
exactly the whole theme of this is that
broken people with great power can also
be world Enders and that's not okay
either and The Vindicator ship seems
like their version of The Avengers
Helicarrier and notice how they're V
logo has the same design as the Avengers
logo you can see it on their monitors on
the table but also on new boobs broom
and Rik staffer later now let's examine
each Vindicator in detail supernova is
voiced by Gillian Jacobs who played
Britta on community the last show that
Dan Harmon worked on you may remember
Joel McHale Jeff Winger was in episode 2
now supernova seems to be based on
characters like storm and the Phoenix
version of Jean Grey with her cosmic
design kind of similar to Aleta award
and when she summons her powers later
her overdramatic speech is kind of
similar to storm from the animated
series your mother yeah what storm
everything has to be epic then there's
million ants who's a super bonkers mix
of characters like Groot and ant-man
made up of a million sentient ants
working in unison controlled by a queen
so that means he can get shot and
regenerate kind of like Sandman
actually notice whenever blood and guts
splatter on them throughout this episode
the ants absorb and devour it also when
the indicators drop down on this planet
Morty rides million ants and uses the
ants to cushion his fall
now personality-wise million ants
emotionally calm vacant demeanor is
reminiscent kind of of dr. Manhattan
from Watchmen his romantic relationship
with supernova it seems parallel to dr.
Manhattan's relationship with Silk
Spectre and brief spoiler alert if you
haven't read or seen Watchmen but a
million ants violent killing of Allen
rails is very similar to dr. Manhattan's
killing of Rorschach fun fact the
animators said that million ants was
planned a beside kick maimed three more
ants next up is croc ubot who's pretty
much this group cyborg from Justice
League now notice how Rick makes fun of
him here your pack cold unfeeling
reptile half also cold equally unfeeling
machine Wow so your origin is what you
fell into a vat of redundancy
Danu nope now this of course is a nod to
the origin of the Joker and let's face
it a lot of superhero characters who
fell into open back chemicals
see I guess in comic books big bats
don't have lids actually listening
closely to crack a boat's voice later on
it kind of sounds a lot like Tom Hardy's
Bane from The Dark Knight Rises Rick
actually references Batman a different
time with Allen rails who like Bruce
Wayne saw his parents die when he was a
young boy
he's voiced by the actor Lance Reddick
from the wire and fringe now Allen's
power to summon a ghost train with a
whistle is super dumb it's kind of like
the most extreme version of all the dumb
things at Green Lantern can create now
of course Green Lantern used a ring
whereas Allen uses this train whistle
and all of his catchphrases are train
related holla bah bah bah now lastly
there is vance Maximus renegade star
soldier he's the cool guy with the suit
and all the one-liners he's of course a
mix of Iron Man Tony Stark and star-lord
Peter quill he's voiced by the actor
Christian Slater he might know from mr.
robot he's been in a ton of movies and
these shots to advanced his severed legs
jetting around wildly seem to be a nod
of the parts of Tony Stark's armor in
Iron Man 3
finally the riskless episode just
features some generic criticisms of the
superhero genre from Rick the five
personality troops are all things that
apply to pretty much every movie
superhero notice how Morty just moved
each of them directly above the spot
that it already was in all of the
descriptors apply to all of you drunk
Rick's point is that none of you are
very special or different that's always
his point and then later this episode
Rick says this about Vindicator your
pretentious poorly written high budget
friends back there okay so this whole
episode is also kind of a sequel from a
past episode like notice how Morty has
this stamped Morty Adventure card in the
first scene Rick hates letting Morty to
the adventure because remember the last
time we saw more to do that was in
season 1 the meeseeks and destroy'
episode which had the infamous encounter
with mr. jellybeans and both of these
episodes begin with morty excited to
lead rick on an adventure that appeals
to his boyhood fantasies but it ends
with a very dark loss of that innocence
and this exact threat is clearly on
Rick's mind throughout the episode
notice the dialogue with Vance
I never forget a kid buddy save
indicators let's make this three
he say three four three did you say he
never forgets a kid luckily this is just
a reference to how superhero actors do
nice things for kids dance actually
confess system or deed later this is the
case this whole adventure is just their
version of when in our world the city of
San Francisco turned itself in a Gotham
City for the make-a-wish Foundation Oh
remember that wasn't that nice no you
don't want to feel any real emotion you
just want to last okay actually this
joke of Rick and Morty reacting to
different things they've called back
later in this episode with morning once
again upset by the indicators
disappointing him and Rick just alarmed
by the creepy sexual connotation just
let City bean do this snuggles it's for
the greater good
now let's comb through and go through
some other details that I really like
this episode back in that first scene
when the vinda beacon lights up Rick
says this cater refused to answer a
literal call to adventure Morty let it
go to voicemail this is another instance
of justin roiland and dan harmon making
an inside joke from the writers burn the
call to adventure is a writing and
storytelling term it's an early step of
Joseph Campbell's hero's journey story
structure really applies to all stories
dan harmon actually famously adapted
this structure into his own circular
story structure model later on Mordy
brings up the three former of indicators
who died in the last battle they lost
lady katana Calypso Diablo Verde yikes
okay so it's interesting that Morty
brings up these three form of indicators
you can actually see them on his tablet
they're a little unclear so let's zoom
in a ham now the reason I want you to
see these is that these three exact
characters show up at the end of the
episode where if we're saying zoomed and
enhanced you can see three of the
cardboard cutouts and Rick's thing that
he made for Morty our lady katana
calypso and Diablo verde actually if you
look at the rest of those cutouts you
can see a building that looks like the
Daily Planet and the character from
Greek mythology Perseus he's writing a
unicorn Pegasus and holding the severed
head of Medusa so I'm guessing that
maybe there was a passive indicator who
kind of like Thor was based on ancient
mythology and while we're zooming and
enhancing let's do an enhanced on the
background of Rick's videos you can see
the cut-up leftover cardboard scraps as
well as the neutrino bomb that shows up
at the end of the episode as well as
this weapon up on the shelf in the top
right this looks like the arm cannon of
the cyborg version of Rick that we saw
in these season 3 trailer so
I think this weapon is foreshadowing
next episode and hell we're having fun
zooming in Hanson so let's do it in
other parts of the episode first there's
this small animation detail I love how
the thing that Rick whips up to clear of
his hungover vision is actually a tiny
creature you can see it smiling down on
him right before he squeezes the juice
out of it and there's lots of little
references that pop up in the whole
design of this cave the walls are
covered in skulls and bones and one of
the skulls of a triceratops also I don't
know if you caught this but over the
door in the final room there's the
skeleton of the alien that chased Rick
and Morty on the Omega seed planet in
the very first episode also you may have
noticed that Rick posed the corpses of
world Enders minions in sexual position
some are in missionary these two are 6
and 9 and each other and throughout this
big saw death trap there's actually a
couple references to other things the
clock for the first trap stops at 42
seconds which could be a reference to
the Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy in
which the answer to life the universe
and everything is revealed as the number
42 Douglas Adams books are kind of a
spiritual ancestor to the way Rick and
Morty blend science fiction and dark
comedy with an overall cynical attitude
towards existence also notice how in the
second trap video Rick is wearing this
Sherlock Holmes deerstalker hat that is
a reference to the finale of the BBC
show Sherlock which had a similar course
plot structure of a villain locking the
heroes in a psychological house of
horrors and topping them from video
screen okay so the party at the end of
the episode is emptied by the real-life
rapper logics and yeah all of these
guests are pretty much the same house
party guests in the season 1 finale
risky business so the animators reused
both summers friends Nancy the nerdy
flute player as well as the Rosie Perez
looking girl with a cargo pants of
course gearhead Rivoli o´clock berg jr
who also showed up in Morty Knight run
in season 2 he is the focus of this
episode post-credit scene there's also
the trap floor Kean's the stair goblin
who originally showed up in these seeks
and destroy there's also the greeby
bobe's the frog light creatures whose
planet portal schnapps was destroyed and
gets swifty hold it hold it stop music
isn't about competition or captivity if
you love music you love freedom let
these wolves be free please just call
there's one every season there's empty
apps - first appeared in Rik potion
number nine and then there's this veiny
dude with a Bart Simpson shirt who if
you look closely is weakened at burning
world Enders corpse at this party but as
I mentioned before world ender isn't the
one ending worlds in this episode the
return of world ender applies to
different characters for one supernova
is far more villainous she confesses to
exterminating the entire planet of
Dorian v just to kill the shapeshifter
do Namit Ron and then she discreetly
gets away at the end of this episode but
really the main world end of this
episode is Rick what's he doing in the
opening scene he's making Morty retrieve
a bunch of sterility slugs so that he
can use them in the future to sterilize
a species and really world indeed has
always been a prospect that Rick has
been far too comfortable with he
approved of unity assimilating an entire
planet and auto-erotic assimilation and
he threatened to destroy the Microverse
universes and the Rick's Muncie crazy
here Rick destroyed Morty's worldview
that The Vindicator czar heroic and he
does it for totally petty reasons he's
just jealous you can't stand to not be
the coolest hero in his grandson's world
so he ends that world now to be fair
drunk Rick's intention was that after
doing that he would win Morty back with
this sincere expression of love notice
how the answer to the final puzzle what
it's the only thing Rick values and The
Vindicator is indeed Morty but drunk
Rick's pettiness prevents them from
truly connecting with his grandson his
drunk rambling wanders into a thank you
to news noob of random background
character just for laughing at his jokes
when no one else would
meanwhile noob noob spends its episode
cleaning up Rick's [ __ ] while Rick
doesn't even remember who he is in the
final line of the episode give knew -
who do you think is more of the world
ending villain of this episode supernova
or Rick help me solve this mystery in
the comments below and tweet me your
thoughts at EA vas or the new rock stars
at new rockstars subscribe and share
this video and if you like you can
contribute to us on patreon big thanks
to all recurring donors especially
Kristina Armstrong alright thanks for
watching see you next week bye